let's talk turkey where is the decision
that happens privately between you two
of we love our show
next
bigger more what is that moment oh my
gosh joe you got that some i think
sometimes we have to go so backwards and
are remembering for us because it's such
a different we have such a different you
know for us we were naive we said yes to
a show we actually didn't know what it
was going to turn into we really thought
just waco was going to watch it and our
parents were going to be proud we didn't
know it was going to go beyond waco so
we stepped into something and then the
whirlwind happened from like 2013 to you
know five years we don't even we look
back we didn't remember what happened
and yet
when is the moment that you go we love
this we want our own network
i think when it when you understand the
why and the intention and then we say we
can become passionate about that we have
said no to so many things but the things
we say yes to is because is it because
it aligns with our vision on what we
want to create here on earth so what did
the network align with your vision and
goals we want to highlight beautiful
humans that are doing things they're
passionate about there's no script
there's no plan it's hey we can we step
into your world and highlight what
you're doing to make it a more beautiful
place whether that's in food home
helping people with their weight and
their fitness and you know well-being
all it doesn't matter it's just i love
what you're doing can we highlight this
and so that's how we've built the
network and to hear that from you is so
wonderful because it's so in keeping
with the good intention
but it is amazing
an important lesson that you can stay so
well intended and grow
to
infinite heights
and may that be the takeaway
and you've been so giving of yourselves
what is one thing that would really
shock people about you or at least
surprise and delight
that we don't know about you all right
let's go
jojo is a wild woman when you turn off
the lights i'm insane
i think that would common what's that
she's a real candidate talking about i'm
just saying when you turn down the light
she explodes in energy what was it oh
god help me okay so you're naughty i
love this and a real time cat and stuff
chick what would as alas gonna be the
headlines yeah right i love it
i love swinging let's go by the way the
cat in the sack could be a good name for
the rock
i love you dad the swinger chip last
question what would shock
us about you
is there a quick quick
thought first of all chip is you see
what you get so there's not a lot people
see so many different layered onions say
he is so
thoughtful and so um he wants to connect
so much like i think i think a lot of
people think he's like a guy's guide
he's like
he
every morning it's just sitting there
going are you to wait are you going to
wake up you know i've got your coffee
you want to talk your coffee he's like
trying to get me to touch those feelings
that are way deep down inside and i'm
like not i'm just tired and i don't want
to find them yet so chip is such a
he's such a sweet so he's like really
like he he's destructive and he does all
the things that people see him do but
he's got this little bitty boy heart
that is so sensitive and so thoughtful
he's like the biggest oxymoron to me
he's the toughest guy i know but the
softest guy sometimes i just want to
snuggle and he loves to snuggle but what
what you need a cat in the sack cat
inside you know they don't snuggle
could you just do me a favor and tell
men don't play the game of chicken call
the girl yes call the girl just just
just
just call the girl
thank you chip and joanna
[Music]
you